it's the restaurant dream yeah someone
cuz that someone fall down yeah good to
go order right there Wow
[Music]
in and out is the poster child of LA's
burner seen nationwide but to get to the
soul of the city's burger obsession you
have to head to Apple Pat the 70 year
old Westside institution embodies the
burger in its purest form serve that a
counter and wrapped in paper by lifelong
staffers nobody loves Apple pen more
than my boy burger historian George Motz
today moats and I are going to dig into
why the Apple pen deserves to be called
LA's quintessential burger George last
time we hung out we were at your house
is like the burger museum for me and now
we're on the west coast were in Los
Angeles where I guess like in like your
church I have a few churches out here
but this is what was probably one of the
most important all right yeah they're
the keepers of a tradition their keepers
of this tradition of taking a burger
wrapping in wax paper and just slap it
in front right see that's really all
over hamburger culture should be about
those cases should be something that's
very quick very immediate and it serve
you know yes Apple pet is my favourite
burger spot I'd say in the world oh yeah
I mean like stopping and grabbing a
burger it was almost like a homage to
like you know very important place what
is it about this place that makes it
like a bucket-list spot one of like the
mount Rushmore's of burgers in this
country the birds the Apple pan are
important because they actually hold the
key to LA is hamburger history it hasn't
changed that's the most important thing
is that there's nothing new about the
place look around and it's not 22 cents
anymore hey sorry $2 you look around
it's almost as if like 1940s Canyon to a
friend's and no one told them except
I've always been attracted to old things
you know I'm an old soul I'm getting old
but I'm actually old soul at heart I
always try to find those old thing oh
you're used to like the real trendy
burger joints with like the EDM playing
and like the like sparkling water that
looks like Cologne
I don't go to those places exactly and
this is like a place like in the middle
of the west side of Los Angeles yeah
looks like it's just that cutout of like
Main Street USA
it looks like a Dorothy's house was like
in Wizard of Oz just spun here and
dropped here it's been here for 71 years
now 71 years along you know that's so
long you know the number one factor to
lasting that long
other than being free burger it's my
business eat burger the burger that I
ate here when I first came here in the
early 90s right safe zephyr I just had
before you walk in the door really hides
that one in give me a little history
about loss sadness I can say I'm born
and raised here like I know in and out I
know Apple pen but I don't know why well
to understand LA is burger history have
to actually start in the Midwest 1920s
burger culture was exploding across
America thanks to white cast which set
out to clean up the burgers low the
image the white stood for feminists and
the castle signified strength at the
exact same time westward expansion and
car culture kicked into high gear with
the war on the depression over and the
rise of expendable incomes California
became a destination it was there that
the driving culture explode introducing
new era burgers serve wrapped and
consumed in your car
what handed as you merge under the
19:48 Harry Steiner invented a two-way
speaker system and his tiny burger stand
in and out which became the first
drive-through in America all of this
innovation was happening in Southern
California to set the stage for burgers
like the one here at Apple fan you've
passed the baton to me let's eat I'm
hungry
man Victor I've been working here for 43
years
cheeseburger have been good to me send
my son through the school my name is
Manuel coming here how much do I love
the Apple pan well how many stars are in
the sky sunny Sherman third-generation
my grandparents started my mom me it's a
good feeling to know that is their
favorite burger you know you can't ask
for more than that
I want this to end so I can
[Music]
this is a pretty full order we've got
here most important that we've got one
of each burger we've got the Hickory
burger and we've got the steak burger
right they look similar right but
they're not or not
because here's the difference though is
that the Hickory burger has a I got a
kind of a tangy sweet barbecue Hickory
sauce right Moki you know sauce on it
right the steak burger is it's basically
the same construction but it adds it
takes away the Hickory sauce adds like a
sweet relish right I ordered fries but I
don't gonna leave fries they have really
good fries here I always get milk cuz
that for some reason for the last 30
years I've been coming here I've always
gotten milk thrown away yeah I also get
cheese yeah there's there's a whole
secret menu I didn't know that there's
like a tuna melt there's a grilled
cheese yeah but I like to get the cheese
fries and what is that that's not
kitchen this is a side other like
they're Hickory sauce if you like like
do this and it's kind of like creating
your own animal style fries I can't help
myself that's a good idea
yeah here number one they slap it down
it stands straight out right I try doing
that on your own as possible I could
never get wrap a burger twice like that
have to stand upright how they do it
twice rats and putting the animal yeah
so it actually stands up straight which
is there's no no need for a plate no
knife chops no no no Navi mr. Bligh's
that right great classic la style which
I love that's loaded with lettuce and
loaded with all kinds of veggies in
there look at that so these guys only
use the center part of the iceberg
lettuce right they're probably only
getting about four or five burgers per
head of lettuce there's so much lettuce
in there it's almost like its own like
lettuce pass out what's like it's like a
sucks you got a Oh all right I've got
pickles on there also heat up the sauce
so and that's supposed to be grease be
preachy cheese become part of salad also
yeah this is my exception I usually
don't get lettuce but I have to have you
here Cheers good to see you man good to
see you it here yes sir
I've had the steak burger in a while
this is the [ __ ] man I'm like actually
really good this taper is really bright
they also the use Tillamook cheddar now
every place is that their classical
places use American chalk is a very very
mild and melty cheddar cheese and just
took a bite of the Hickory and you know
it's still my favorite I know the
smokiness makes the beef amplify yeah
this place has been copied a lot not
just a look but all through this
adventure as well they found someone in
the dumpster they passed I went dumpster
diving looking for the reflector late
breasted reasons of the low key for the
camp ready yeah
they won't know what tune they use but
kind of you know what was what was going
into the food right so they put they put
a lock on the dumpster dumpster down
locked up
this place is influences you to new york
season what are you doing in LA season
right what do you think you have a
favorite la better than New York that's
different in LA I feel like I eat
burgers a lot more it's like eating a
PowerBar yeah but in New York get ready
for it yeah press it out a lot of time
doses solidified itself as yeah a real
burger destination as far as like we
have the backbone yeah don't worry the
history bitchiness and in New York I
mean I'm not hating I Love New York
we're in far between to find the good
one sometimes exactly you will not find
in most restaurants in America not even
LA somehow our servers that have been
here for over 30 years protector
how long have you been here now we're
sitting at 41 what do you give this what
42 years right never 42 pretty new man I
can could barely keep a light tug at my
at my place for more than a year yeah I
mean this side of the campus 42 years
are you the oldest law mr. big
forty two and a half oh yeah Lupe hello
Lupe's boobies been here for the 25 oh
yeah
25 20 25 years you guys it's like a team
like as a restaurant owner as a burger
lover
that's a cook yeah that's it's something
to admire vacuum right I you know II
know but this is not holy yeah Anatole
about two years but it's good to know
the places like the Apple pay exist
right that really gives you hope that
the other hamburger cultures is alive
and well I know I'll be here that's you
know me too until the casket drops my
name is Jorge Medina thank you for 20
years I've been working up 38 years a
lot has changed around here everything
has changed but not this the first thing
I think about is the way that everyone's
sitting around everyone needs each other
you make friends it's excited he's
excited is that you thousand you know
like don't you never stop it's all about
relationships here you're building trust
with someone over the years that's why
people come back because you kind of you
have to earn that now it smell like do I
want to Hickory do I want to state steak
burger with cheese Hickory burger with
cheese gild Travolta what he wants Jean
Kerry be here I believe you got a
hickory cheese burger fries and I cook
steak burger and pie but it's not a
complete experience as you know you're a
be Apple man you don't get oh I have to
get pie
yeah goodbye yes so they're like the
last chapter of the story I usually ask
for pies but why I sit down because I'm
afraid they're not gonna have it
actually what's all this a to be do you
walk by it
what is it doesn't know I went burger no
no you want to buy a fur yeah yeah
protip order to the pie before the
burger so it doesn't run out I pick the
Apple right here Apple they had a creepy
part look at that apple pie on the mode
apple pie with vanilla ice cream and bad
a cream pie look at that beard look at
that this must be like four bananas this
one slice at Louise org
we got custard the custard is on the
[ __ ] this is heaven for meat here this
is like the love letter to the burger
lover in Los Angeles I agree it's really
just my go-to place it's
it's like therapy almost me too I guess
yes thought about that one come here pop
nothing else [ __ ] matters yeah like
everything else matters when you're here
I thought I couldn't top making burgers
with you in your kitchen but you know
having Apple pads sharing some fire with
you man
this is epic for me bro yeah you know me
too man thank you thanks dear thank you
appreciate I might call you spot pumping
if you got crushed ice in a Styrofoam
cup with the refill right so homey the
water your mountain to the next belief
show I'm out on the streets looking for
something to keep my Elvis order a hippo
burger with no cheese I don't like
cheese
sup guys i have a kai-lan for the burger
show thank you for watching hit the like
button hit the subscribe button if not
for me for the burgers please and thank
you